the honeybee a tiny hero in a big world
honeybees are the most important
pollinators
pollinating almost a hundred crops
[Music]
making it the most fruitful job in the
world
but without them
life as we know it will end
holy [ __ ]
and bees are in trouble
guys pay the [ __ ] attention
this is important years
millions of bee colonies have been lost
all around the world
[Music]
besides their natural enemies like birds
or parasites
bees must deal with new dangers
pesticides low nutrition and viruses
which all weaken our natural pollinators
[Music]
so listen to our story of the bee hero
to see how even the smallest slides can
matter
it's like the starfish story
you can be the change need another e in
there you ever wanted to be a [ __ ]
bee
sorry welcome to b simulator where you
can be the be all you can be you can be
all you can be be you can be the bee
that all you can be you can be the bee
with all you can be
you can be
this is a peaceful game i don't know why
you're yelling i'm gonna pick a profile
give me hard
give it to me hard and also yes
everything that they were saying about
the bees being uh like in danger is true
watch out for the bees bees are lovely
bees are so cute
bees are so harmless most of the time
anyway
let's be a bee
let's be all the bee that we can be
let's be the bee that we can be let's be
all be that we can be let's be the be
it's b time
hello
am i baby b
my sweet baby b
am i a sweet delightful baby oh
are
those my arms
are those my little baby arms
or my mouth or my antennae
wake up
i'm awake
wait god god flashbacks to damien
hello hi oh
was that me
hello you hi me
hive sweet
finally here
this looks amazing
a new hatchling
hi little one what's your name
oh
biscuit god
that's too goddamn cute that's so
goddamn cute well first things first
let's do this fly like a bee okay go on
let's get those wings moving all right
thanks for you my mom kind be
alice oh
wsda
wow
that was something now get to the
construction room the what room
the what room
follow the golden markers they always
show the way
whoa
[Music]
i'm a freaking uh how do i rotate oh god
oh wow that is slow rotation
okay
i'm in it to win it
how do i rotate let's have a little more
mouse sensitivity i think
oh there we go need a lot more mouth
sensitivity we have a special place
where you can learn how to be a bee just
fly through this crack
no need to tell me twice
what crack what crack crack crack that
crack oh oh my i need way more
sensitivity on this bam give me all of
it
oh that's better
[Music]
wow
oh it's beautiful
oh my god i'm so used to playing
simulator games that are just pure jank
i didn't expect this to actually be
amazing
[Music]
we
this out we this is walcott
right
we are family all right
okay
oh
oh wow
oh wow
oh wow
oh wow
i've never wanted to be a bee so badly
in my life i want to be the best bee i
want to make my family very proud of me
god to have a place in society oh my god
they have a purpose oh my god
this is way too fast i love this
my god i love it i've never loved
anything more in my life than this in
this moment
in this instance i can never be happier
than i am right now
i have never been happier i will never
be happier than
freaking collecting pollen as a bee
look how freaking beautiful this is
what is this
oh
oh i oh i deposited
oh that was a that was a hive i thought
i came from the hive but apparently that
was so
it's a depository hive
flowers do i have any kind of bee vision
that might oh is that sting i don't
think i want to do that i'm pretty sure
that ends with my demise
hi snail
hi
sting
get your
that's right you run you hide oh there
we go
[Music]
there we are alice i did it
alice i did it the world is filled with
different flowers which our vision sees
in different colors
use b vision to identify flower quality
white flowers are common green uncommon
yellow rare and red epic purple are
legendary activate b vision you got it
oh
oh yeah
oh yeah i'm gonna want these green o's
i want the red boys
[Music]
oh purple up there i see you
oh wow wait hey hey
hey oh clicked ow it specifically wants
red
well whatever that's kind of dumb i
think i know what's best for the colony
this alice doesn't know what's going on
doesn't know the real needs of the bees
not like me
i know exactly what it's called
now you're full of beetroot
i'm full of what we use
as a power up to fly faster try it out
you'll feel like a rocket
what vitro is a special b speed boost
the arrow indicator on the bottom left
shows your beetro energy fill it up by
collecting pollen from several flowers
of an identical type in a row or by
eating humans throughout the park vitro
it's not shift i changed that okay watch
this
it's q now
why is it q shut up that's why
wow
how
[Music]
that's pretty good
that's pretty good i'm not gonna lie
that's pretty good and there's this
i've unlocked the sweet flower in the
glossary
i love that for me all right what am i
doing talk to alice
bam
i love this game i love this game so
much
never say wowzers to me ever again alice
a proper knows how to deposit her
collected pollen i already did
i'm way ahead of you sis go on give it a
try i already did it
jeez god looks like this place needs
some new management around here all of
their problems come down to bad
leadership look at my flower power look
at it then look at yours and then weep
how
ow
okay okay there we go you will
automatically drop your pollen when
you're close to a hexagonal wall you
can't collect polymer while your honey
pot is full
my what my what find the golden marker
and get a new task from alice why what
am i getting from this alice follow the
tunnel to return to the hive
all right you oh this way well i didn't
come from that way but whatever vitro go
bam honey was found in the tombs of
egyptian pharaohs from thousands of
years ago and it was still edible god
damn that's some good honey
oh hello red portal of ominous dude all
the basics i'm ready to start on my new
tasks am i talking to myself queen
damaris
well you must be very eager to get to
work mom
where's mom i am but i don't know what i
should be doing there are many different
jobs in the hive scouts guards nannies
but most of us are honeybees like me
okay
wow i get to choose my job
oh no silly
you must go see her
okay all right
i like it
destiny queen mom
mom
i had a bad dream
that was a wee
mom
i can't i don't have any bitro in here
whoa
whoa mom you're big
holy crap mom
what have you been eating
mom
mom
wow i'm really dancing
okay
why do you approach our queen uh well
hush my gods
let my newest child approach me
hi
hi mom okay looking a little high and
mighty there mom seems like we need a
change of leadership here
you are a honeybee now oh
i don't get to talk about it into the
world collect pollen for the hive
anyway ma i love you i'm just going to
give you a little summer will soon be
over
don't tilly dally
hi
[Music]
come on come on make me queen make me
the queen
if i do this a hundred times i bet i bet
it i bet it gives me i bet it gives it
to me wham all right fine bye i guess
i'll just go work until i die
thanks mom
thank you
i really feel the purpose i'll probably
feel better once i'm outside you know
i don't see the forest for the trees
while i'm inside though
[Music]
man the insect world is probably
terrifying from the perspective of an
insect ooh bees give directions by dance
i can dance
that's news to me
oh my god it is beautiful
oh hi dear
wow look at that
i guess i'm on my own now
i guess i just live out my days as a bee
oh
i'm trying not to die i suppose
it said that this was hard mode and i
don't even know exactly what that means
hmm i wonder if i could just fly off
into the city
all right anyway
oh
hi bees
i hope you're bees
oh hi okay
oh
okay
ow ow hey
what the hell
okay well this world sucks
it was once filled with beauty and
splendor about traffic i need to be more
careful you need to be more careful
all right let's gather some
pollen okay whoa why do i have such a
limited amount of time
what is that all about all right
whatever i'm just gonna go gather and
i'll sting that moose and i'll get on
with my day and maybe mom will be
impressed with me then
well this is nice it's really nice this
is nice
faster
this is nice faster
faster speed speed speed speed speed
speed yes yes yes yes this is the
greatest game i've ever played in my
life skip
not today you're not gonna get me like
that i'm gonna get the sequence i'm full
i collect
four yellows oh i can do that i guess
oh i'm dead now oh there is a bee over
there and she doesn't look well where
did you freaking hurt that bee
i'll kill you i'll kill you right on
your freaking eye bro i'm gonna stab you
in your goddamn eyes
[Music]
this is my figure picnic you idiots all
right anyway let's see what this bee's
doing hey why are you being lazy mom's
gonna be real disappointed in you
hello are you all right
do you need help getting back to the
hive
oh
what
i don't feel so good
yeah i know i could see that
spinning
you
leave me alone
okay well all right i'll leave you
follow the other bee try not to miss the
colored rings watch out for obstacles
apparel
well this seems strange
oh where'd you go
oh okay
well good thing i'm known for my
incredible speed
you can't miss
lose me i think
ah
oh
got it
power-ups
bistro
[Music]
hey come back
[Music]
yeah i know i'm trying to help you you
idiot
oh this is dopazil
oh
[Music]
[Music]
did i do it
[Music]
that kid really is dancing must be
filming a tick tock
really proud of that kid
oh [ __ ]
you nosy little bee okay no need to be a
vih
you will pay for disturbing my meal okay
well i could kick your ass you know oh
yeah we'll see
yeah we will see attacked and defend by
choosing the correct direction with the
attacker block buttons when the
opportunity arrives use the special
blocking maneuvers and attacks the
yellow indicator shows up when you can
perform a special dodge or special
attack okay so
i don't know what this is i'm just gonna
guess
sure
i've got you okay
ha ha
[Music]
wow
you kind of suck
ha ha
i get it now
countered [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's what i thought
haha
oh
god
haha your defenses are broken and i'm
going to kick your ass
that's what you get
oh you're dead now you're literally dead
a friend i'm dead dude because i know
how bees work
anyway kicked your ass
i like that i could kick its ass i
thought i'd have to run away
just you wait
yes you wait my friends are gonna come
and find you i killed them it says you
come out now
you can go home
uh
i remember now good
i ate a piece of a rotten apple
it tastes really funny
oh
i feel so sick
we're all family every one of us
one big family
sweets humans leave a lot of food lying
around and then there's fruit too you
can gain vitro energy by munching on
them
nice
that's a good day's work time to go home
that's a good day's work wait i'm not
done my my pollination is not full
[Music]
okay i'm full now i'm going home
i'm gushing it with the bistro
hey what are you doing hey hey hey hey
hey hey hey
hey hey hey
humans they've never come this close
before hey
what do you want with our tree
hey
freaking not know what to do with your
neck i kicked a wasp's ass i could kick
your ass
fine whatever
[Music]
honeycomb is a collection of wax cells
built by worker bees
oh
i don't like a cinematic
cinematic with ominous music kinda seems
bad
[Music]
hi mom
hush
oh
humans are trying to destroy our tree
they give up for now but they will be
back soon to take away our home
[Music]
do not be afraid
from this day on
all of the scouts but only them are
obliged to search for a new place for us
to live
as for the rest
get back to your duties
you got it mom i love it the authority
i love the authority
although i feel like i could be better
authority
on the compass you will always find the
hive and quest location symbols
challenge symbols are only visible when
you're nearby ooh i need to drop off
pollen you're god damn right i do work
we still need more epic pollen for the
winter we need more epic paul and you
got it but epic pollen is hard to find
not for me
we have a library
what
what do you mean we have a library
listen
i might know not know a lot about bees
and i might be incredibly high but i'm
pretty sure
that bees do not have libraries i'm
fairly certain about that
oh this reminds me of oh my god i just
got a weird flashback to uh black and
white the game
god i love that game it had a uh it had
a library like this inside the temple
man i had the weirdest flash i haven't
thought about that game in so long
i love that game i kind of want to play
it again now
weird
i should
i don't even know what that said
and i'll honestly i don't even care i'm
gonna go fly outside now goodbye
everybody good luck i'm gonna start my
own hive with blackjack and hookers
you'll all see you puny bees i'm gonna
be a better queen than you ever were mom
what's up
shut up
[ __ ] shut up
shut up i don't have time for you i'm
too important supposedly if you kill the
bee the visitor won't be pleasant yeah
that sounds right
in the library oh my god okay old b
jamie let me tell you something oh my
god shut up old bj me
uh
[Music]
[Music]
sure you will grandma
sure you will oh god oh no
okay i'll remember it simon says
[Music]
got it
[Music]
how did that transfer any kind of
information is that true is that
accurate to bees
that's crazy may the pollen be with each
knowledge point by completing the moment
okay all right how about i do none of
that i just want to gather pollen it's
like minecraft all i want to do is just
dig
i just want to dig a hole in the ground
that's all i've ever wanted to do can i
have this cupcake i hope you weren't
going for it kid cause it is mine
that's some good stuff
and away i go
now those are big animals yeah they are
if the old bee was right i should be
getting close now hmm
the old b might have been an idiot you
ever think about that the old b might
have been insane driven to be madness by
the herbicides
i'll take that ma'am i'll take that
ma'am
thanks ma'am
what a beautiful place
so many animals and humans
but i must focus and find the flower
lady
i think i found her
pretty sure i found her
pretty sure excuse me
wow i can smell some vampire yeah i kind
of got it already guys
oh
no
no
now
oh just when i was learning to live my
be life
i was just finding my wings
oh god damn i was actually having a
great time
oh well
got well i found that
those legendary flowers hit too hard
they just hit real hard hit like a
goddamn truck oh i'm back yes
that is good
my god
time froze for a while
there are other bees around
in the right direction
nah nah screw them
oh fast b jordan i don't want to talk to
fast b jordan fast b jordan's a dick hey
do you know any rare flowers around here
sure one race if you catch me i'll tell
you about the flower oh my god i don't
want to race you i just want to collect
pollen all right whatever i'll kick your
ass i'll kick your ass i'll kick your
ass i'll kick your ass you want me to
kick your ass i'll kick your ass hey
i'll kick your ass hey don't worry about
it i'll kick your ass oh god where are
you going where are you going where are
you going ow
where are you going
[Music]
i'll kick your ass i'll kick your ass
you want me kick your ass i'll kick your
ass
oh
good race you got me i got you hey i
don't know how i got you but i got you
flowers in the traffic zone oh my god
the tropic zone thank you
thank you for nothing no i won't listen
i don't care what you have to say i'm
not listening i'm gonna go find these
flowers and you're gonna shut up forever
[Music]
whoa is this the tropic zone
oh
whoa
wow what an amazing place
and i can already smell the flowers
i sure can
[Music]
okay red flowers
not exactly what i was hoping for but
i'll take it
okay cool got him
oh
i'm clear i can just collect flowers now
excellent
excellent
whoa hey whatever
whoa
easy there bucko hey kid you won't be
stung on the eyeball
bam run the eyeball all right well that
was great
wow kid you go you go with your fortnite
dances this has been b simulator you
know being a b not the worst thing in
the world i kind of love it i almost
wish there was a lot less
objective based
like things i get that there's a lot to
learn but i almost feel like the magic
of being a bee is just being out in the
world and exploring and you find the
objectives along the way but at the same
time you know
you can't have too much fun being a bee
yeah you better be scared
yeah you should be scared
hope you're not allergic anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you enjoyed this video
uh if you want more simulator games i
got a playlist full of them down in the
description below thank you again and as
always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you